a lot of people saying the Warriors
Dynasty are over which are the same
people that said it was over in 2019
Katie live four years later they're
still saying it's over great they're
always wrong it's not those same people
are the same folks that said I'd never
make it in the NBA those people are the
same folks and so they're a jump
shooting team and they won't win it's
those people but also know and pay
attention to who the people that are
saying the dynasty over it's always
people that never been a part of a
dynasty you never really see Shaquille
O'Neal the great Shack my favorite
player as a kid growing up say oh man
it's over you know why because that man
understand what it's like he gets it but
there's always people that run and say
oh man it's over you don't even know how
it feels to start it